kommen wir zum Nikken und die Queroaxe.
Die Queroaxe, diese Achse durch den Schirm, wir haben die Queroaxe, wir haben die Längsachsumme, wir haben die Rohrachsumme.
Die Bewegung und die Queroaxe, das nennt man Nikken.
Ist für das wichtig, dass wenn wir beispielsweise die Termik einfliegen,
das ist ein sehr guter Pilot, der das beherrscht.
Bei Nikken immer darauf achten, dass wir mit der Bremse nicht zu früh sind und nicht zu schnell.
Ich führ es euch gleich vor.
Aber das sind die häufigsten Wählerbällen, das einfach zu schnell und zu tief versucht zu ziehen,
um das Nikken stark aufzuschauen.
Es geht auch mehr ums Timing von der Bremse als um die Intensität.
Mit höheren Pendeln müssen wir immer mehr Bremse ziehen, das ist schlugisch.
Klar, kommen wir nicht drumherum.
Aber am Anfang ist entscheidend, dass wir langsam Bremsen und wann wir mit den Bremsen wieder ein weiteres Mal gehen.
Nikken heißt auch, dass wir versuchen mit dem Körper so ein bisschen Kontakt zum Gutzeug suchen.
Also ein bisschen Knie so auseinander drücken.
Den Skirm anschauen, wollen die Flugrichtung anschauen.
Also wir starten nicht nur mit dem Skirm.
Wir starten nicht einfach nur Sturz um Skirm, sondern auch ein bisschen im Blick,
dass wir sehen alles klar, die Richtung geht.
Oder wo geht denn der Skirm überhaupt hin?
Gut, beim Nikken empfehle ich euch die Bremsen nicht zu wickeln.
Sondern die Bremsen am Steg in der Verhand zu behalten.
Weil wir den Skirm durch Bremsen lösen, auch vollständig freigeben können.
Was beim Reibenschlag wiegt dann oftmals nicht der Fall ist.
Okay, gut.
Dann sage ich am Funkerät, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT.
Und mit jedem Mal ziehen, zieht es so 3-4 Zentimeter.
Das bedeutet, zu die ersten 15-20 Zentimeter die Zimme ziemlich langsam.
Ich sage am Funk, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT.
Hände hoch.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Also wirklich langsam beginnen, aber Hände hoch hoch, so schnell wie er könnte.
ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT.
Hände hoch, zapfen, oder?
Das ist richtig züge hoch.
Versuchst vielleicht sogar ein bisschen am Tragenburt,
denn Lagen zu arbeiten bei den Bremsen,
dass man nicht so mit den Bremsen so nach außen hingeht.
Wirklich eine schöne Führung, wahre Lätsam,
dann warten, ganz.
Warten unds.
Und zwar ist es so durch das Andremsen,
pendet ihr nach vorne.
Jetzt warten wir bis der Schirm dahinten am Todpunkt ist
und dann lassen wir die Bremsen gehen,
das heißt der Schirm beschleunigt Vollgas.
Und jetzt müssen wir warten, bis wir hier unter dem Schirm
wieder durchgehendet sind.
Wenn wir den Schirm bei der Abwärtsbewegung bremsen,
nehmen wir eben die ganze Energie weg,
die wir eigentlich gerade, gerade aufgebaut haben.
Und deshalb ist es so wichtig, dass wir warten,
bis wir die ganze Energie, die ganze Geschwindigkeit mitnehmen
und unter dem Schirm verbeiteten.
Das heißt, wir sind wie bei der Schaukel auch schon wieder
leicht in der Abwärtsbewegung.
Und er stand, kommt ein weiteres Mal die Bremsen.
Jetzt beim zweiten oder auch beim dritten Mal.
Einfach ein bisschen tiefer.
Das heißt, Bremsen.
ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT.
Die Motivverhere hoch, zack, oder?
Der ist mal ruhig ein bisschen tiefer, zink, kein Problem.
Beim Handige Geschwindigkeit.
Wenn dann der nicht wie glücklich, zack ich zu euch,
okay, jetzt nochmal ein weiteres Mal bremsen.
Also mach noch einmal.
Das heißt, ihr pendelt unten durch.
Seid ihr ein bisschen in der Steigfase,
dann nochmal ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT.
Heille hoch.
Und jetzt ist so jetzt, dass wir den Schirm noch so nach vorne kommen.
Ich sage mal 45 bis 60 Grad.
Und dann wollen wir den dort vorne stoppen.
very vorne stoppen.
Das heißt, hier vorne stoppen.
Wenn ich sage, zIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT.
Die bremsen Zimme.
Ich sage, Hände hoch.
Wenn ich ist symmetisch und zügig, die Hände hoch.
Und dann sage ich am Vokret warte.
Dann müsste wirklich warten, bis ihr am Schirm vorbeigependelt seid.
Und am Totpunkt durch, nach oben hin und unterwegs.
Und dann kommt von mir auch erst das Kommando.
Bremsen ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, ZIT, Hände hoch.
Beim Bremsen immer darauf achten,
dass wir symmetrisch beginnen.
Wenn ihr rechts ein bisschen eher tiefer als links,
dann machen wir eine kleine Rechtskurve.
Oder wenn ihr beim freigeben,
die Rechte Hände ein bisschen eher als sie linke bringt oder umgekehrt.
Dann machen wir auch da eine Kurve auf die eine Seite.
Und das wäre nicht das Ziel.
Jetzt, das ist so eine Fehlerquelle,
wo passieren kann beim Leben?
Deshalb bitte ich euch einfach am Anfang etwas langsamerat zu gehen.
Ich sage schon Ziller ein bisschen mehr oder noch ein bisschen tiefer.
Wenn ihr zu schnell und zu tief am Anfang zieht,
dann kriegt ihr den Schirm stolen.
Lichtig wäre, wie seht ihr das von unten?
Wie sage ich dann, Hände hoch.
Hände wirklich oben lassen.
Den Schirm anfahren lassen.
Wenn wir den Schirm zu weit in den Stoll sozusagen gezogen haben.
Also der wirklich ein bisschen nach hinten abgekippt ist,
dann kann das sein, dass der Schirm nach vorne beschleunigt
und vorne einklappt.
Und wir laxen das zu.
Wir laxen einfach die Hände oben.
Wir reagieren eventuell nur auf den Klapper.
Das heißt, wenn der Schirm einseitig drinnen verhängt, bleibt,
dann tun wir das mit der Richtung herausnehmen.
Also Richtung stabilisieren.
Aber das kommt dann von mir linke Bremse ziehen
oder rechte Bremse nach dem, was dann der Fall wäre.
In der Regel erholt sich der Schirm von alleine und ohne,
dass wir was machen müssen.
Das ist ein bisschen wichtig.
Sobald wir den Schirm dann doch einmal gesteult haben,
die Hände oben lassen, oben lassen warten,
bis der Schirm sich vor dem ganzen erholt hat.
Falls mir irgendwie eine Klapper-Verhänger,
egal was haben, dann reagieren wir erst auf das.